you're here too I'm here to play risen
yeah pretty well ice well I spit forth
all my my phlegm and saliva
yes directly [ __ ] Rob he's got long
stand I know you brought me on it's
important to get opinions from more
bearded white dudes mhm and that's what
I'm here to do yes we covet your opinion
o bearded white dude so this is of
course the follow-up what do you want
did you just teleport risen to now this
takes place in the same the same setting
as risen too so you go through basically
the same islands that usually compare
yeah it is a pirate setting and you are
sort of a pirate but not anymore so you
do consort with pirates but you don't
necessarily have to be a pirate you
eventually have to side however with one
of the game's many factions like like
for guys bad guys weird guys not really
bad guys they're all it's it's really
one of those things where you're getting
you're trying to band everybody together
to take on the giant you know the the
giant demons and stuff that are that are
overtaking the world you know darkness
has comes and you actually your
character is steel Birds Sun steel
beards being mechanic from from earlier
in the series so you're actually if you
remember patty your first brother
so whoops it's very easy to sometimes
speak to your commanding so you can
always take a companion with you this
time you've got bones
I do have bones but there are several
maybe in a bit I'll go back to the ship
and show you who else either they well
this is maybe about halfway through the
game here I finished on on Sunday you
conquered it I did conquer the game on
Sunday I'm in the process of writing
review now but it's it's interesting
because it's a lot like risen to but the
combat has definitely been made more
fluid a visual
are definitely much better but the
combat still has a lot of problems one
of which is just how its provide a ball
it is that role in particular the dodge
ma yeah is really little blue
exploitable well you don't start that
way that that had it because I that is
that and that happened because I took a
specific I I sided with a specific
faction uh-huh right so so I'm a demon
hunter here so but you get to decide but
the mages with the pirates and so on and
so forth so that teleport oh yeah pick
an ogre pieces one by one yeah but even
before you do that you your role I know
what individual pieces of gold
really this isn't this doesn't happen
too much usually things are in packs or
you steal like that's fine bunch of gold
and of course battles of the last so
when you find stuff like this a lot of
the time you end up earning a new you
know earning something new like a new
quest to go after or sometimes you'll
learn about about treasure locations
that way you just steal a clam from a
dead goblin hopefully goblins always
have class and then what you can do is
see one of the great things about clams
is if I have any like I have shells like
you can be a 46 clam you can and now we
get to click on them all to see how many
might have pearls so I'm just clicking
but you need those pearls like look so
or I actually received and here one of
the reasons I was out here is to get a
shimmering pearl is that a pile of clams
just somebody who's like in a high but
you'd say for every 50 clams is one
pearl well no you can get a bunch of
pearls I needed that specific pearl
because she'd sent me after the pearl so
at this stage though I am off to close
one of the things that you do in this
game is you have to close these portals
that demons come through so that's one
of your ma heavens just coming through
it so right knee and bones who was a
druid he's my favorite companion of all
of them
I I freaked I don't know exactly how
many there are there's like seven or
eight companions something like that
maybe it's only six but it's around that
and he's my favorite the one of the
problems with companions is that a lot
of them kind of are the same like folks
that was already in open its they're
kind of boring so well not I like them
as personalities the problem is that
functionally a lot of them don't really
do much like just in the last it would
jump down there I'm gonna come down here
what else danger and one thing that has
returned from risen is the nauseating
way it handles its camera when you're
leaping or falling but anyway if you've
if you played risen than you which I
speak wow you really are just dropping
down this hole you do take fall damage
but it's great I'm not going down so far
is gravity reduced I already have his
white tree yeah we'll see the thing is
you're also you've lost your spirit so
you can also go into this kind of spirit
mode to help identify certain things but
it's really useless it's such a
superfluous thing that I'm not even sure
why I was left in but yeah so eventually
bones will catch up sometimes companions
have a hard time navigating climb a hard
time gently falling down but and so now
to deal with just a reminder that if you
guys have any questions for Evan about
risen 3 we're taking a look in the
twitch TV / GameSpot chat as well as the
comments on gamespot comm we can pass
them along to him and find out all about
what exactly a Titan Lord is heaven what
is a type well
they're they're basically are they're
Time Lords are there giant versions of
humans that wear no clothes there like
you know there's demigods basically in
this world okay
there's bones I'm just trying to get out
of the way because I wanted to cheat run
shoot my weapon and dead one of the one
of those moves another another you know
nauseating camera movement when when you
get those finishing moves now you can
block I'm now risen to when it was
originally released you couldn't dodge
or block and it was some of the most
frustrating cut bet ever enough like to
stand there and take it yeah well there
were there were ways that you could try
to deal with it but I mean the combat in
that sense as much much improved it's
much more flipping it used to be and it
is the same world but it's it's a lot
different now so I mean they've really
upped the visuals in a lot of ways which
is good it's still not looks like
there's some neat environmental design
going on I like only one guy I mean it's
not visually the most attractive thing
ever I mean there are definitely much
better looking RPGs out there but they
really did clean up a lot of stuff some
of my favorite things are in the in the
character models when you really get in
close some of them used to be really so
is the teleport is that class specific
or is that's when you just picked up
later on
oh that well it's it's not really a
teleport all it is is it's the dodge
with a new animation so it now has the
new animation you just don't see me
dodge anymore actually so it don't see
you at all yeah exactly
but it's functionally exactly the same
nice job you're gonna steal all those
ghouls bones you can't always get bones
one of the most interesting things which
is a carryover is how leveling up works
which is that you you do have like your
individual things that you can level up
like melee and ranged and spirit and
magic and so forth but you to actually
earn new skills you still have to go buy
them and those act as thresholds to the
things that you can actually
my so you buy them with just currency
you buy them with currency buy them with
bone you have to go to a trainer and and
spend gold on those so oh you're quick
Goblin one interesting thing is I mean
the game is a lot easier than risen and
risen to ever were in though in the
first two games it was pretty easy to
die from the very beginning like just to
one of those sand Devils on the beach it
was like that tubs that tiny thing just
murdered me now like that kind of stuff
isn't bound to happen I don't know if I
can line this or not no thing nothing so
I think so shameful is being killed by a
tiny sand thing yeah but now things have
gotten a lot easier the combat is is a
lot more fluid the downside of course is
really exploitable like you can just
exploit that roll to death if you're
wondering like why I'm not blocking yeah
that's one of the reasons because the
Dodge is so it's so powerful that you
you can I mean the game is is compared
to risen and risen to which were much
more difficult this the combat in this
game eventually becomes a cakewalk so in
that sense it's very different until you
get kind of the final boss which is
really frustrating here's the
lock-picking which is interesting in the
early times of the lock-picking like you
can just
I watched you pick a lock so when it's
it was comical it was comical because
something when you only have four of
these things you swipe it across and
back and you're done there's nothing to
it but here like see I can't just do
that because that happens because you
actually have to do it in an order and
you'd have to figure out what that order
is by playing a little bit so okay that
one stays up that one stays up that's
one stays up so now the question is do I
go to the left or go do I go to the
right height oh so that one's not the
right one to go to so you do this and
then this and then you still have to
make a decision which one I'll do that
well not the right one so one was going
to 24 back this one and back to that and
that all right that's how the
lock-picking works but that is way more
interesting than what I saw you do or
when you have any fewer than 6
those than its it's sort of a
meaningless lock-picking system and even
then it's not too difficult believe it
or not two worlds - has my favorite
lock-picking of all time and nobody I
don't believe it nobody ever says
anything this guy's your world stir yeah
here's a swamp golem so they're
different kinds of golems or golems
depending on how you like to have it I
don't want to upset people
how's it spelled oh I would say Gollum
for that for sure Rob yeah sure come on
for Gollum let's do it let's do it we're
going no what I said do some magic here
I'll do some magic just to say hey look
I can do some magic so hope that doesn't
do anything that thing is pretty cool
again roses I like some of the creature
designs here I like the environmental
design is I mean it's exploration sort
of a thing for the biggest thing
actually here willful summon some fire
from above fire from above although
really he's just he's a cakewalk he just
kind of sword him to death now when it
comes to buying certain like buying some
of those skills like you can't always
just get skin everything off of these
creatures every time like you have to
earn the ability to like get bones or
skulls or hides and things like that
Oh to Salva to scavenge them off yeah
creatures and what-have-you see this one
hopefully we got walk picking his life
so in the early times making that
achievement progress well the thing is I
already I think I already a cheat I
think I already have that achievement
maybe I'm playing offline so it it's
only going from where the I was afraid
that the game would update I had a it
kept crashing on the other PC which is I
was afraid to update it in case the
press the press build in the and the
retail but you came out today Kevin is
this a game that is good would you
recommend this game I would like some
where's your review status I think that
you know what you're getting into when
you play a piranha bytes game so these
are the people that made gothic which is
still probably that you know maybe
gothic 2 is the height of what they've
done but you sort of know what you're
getting into you know that you're going
to get a
a game with lots of adventure and lots
of stuff to do in it and lots of cool
places to go and it's gonna be wonky and
weird and not everything is gonna make
sense and it's gonna be clumsy and and
maybe sometimes a little bit broken and
yet it's gonna be kind of special
because there are too few games that do
this and this game does a lot of what it
does really well it just it it really is
one of those games it's like god I wish
they could have tightened up all the
nuts and bolts because it has a lot of
loose knots um yeah but it's it's a
really satisfying game but holds itself
together and like you get you can find
some great enjoyment from playing it Oh
totally and here's I don't have all of
the the companions here at this stage of
the setup is your Normandy this is your
Normandy you don't start with this ship
eventually you only get a big ship once
you align and then all of your
companions join you so this is Horace
alright just talk to Horace I don't want
to need all these these are all
different it's just in combat there's
only one dude that kind of is works
differently he has a shotgun
he's uh he's one of the people from the
Voodoo people that you get so it's like
the same kind of the similar races from
risen to all reappear but you do have
new kinds of magic that you can do like
there was no offensive magic and risen
to now you all sort through some thing
it's crazy when is it is a game out you
said the game is out today today yeah
and review coming the review should be
either tonight or tomorrow morning
alright so I'm just in the process of
writing and so be on the lookout but I
would say yeah if you if you know what
risen is they will do it their eyes or
bat alright